[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 29 octobre
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce journal c'est un
axe important de la vallée de chevreuse
la route des dix sept tournant reprend
du service entre dampierre et saint
forget cette portion de la
départementale 91 été fermé pendant
trois mois pour cause de travaux de
remise en sécurité
elle a été inaugurée en fin de semaine
dernière ce week-end nous sommes
repassés à l'heure d'hiver et il est
probable que ce soit la dernière fois en
février le parlement européen s'est dit
favorable à la suppression du changement
d'heure une association basée à
marly-le-roi elle se bat depuis des
années pour l'arrêt de l'heure d'été
double explication avec sa présidente
qui est notre invité et puis la fin
d'une série noire pour plaisir en rugby
y est le résumé du 6e tour de coupe de
france de football
ce qu'il faut retenir du week-end
sportif dans le département c'est dans
cette édition après trois mois de
fermeture la cote des dix sept tournant
est donc remise en service le conseil
départemental et le maire de saint
forget ont inauguré cette section rénové
de la route départementale 91 vendredi
dernier le reportage de marie lehn
iapichino la route 117 tournant qui part
de dampierre pour rallier saint forget
est à nouveau accessible fermer
totalement à la circulation depuis le 23
juillet elle a fait peau neuve pendant
trois mois ça changeait complètement les
habitudes des gens salariale est obligé
de faire des détours de prendre des
précautions de prendre du temps pour les
enfants à l'école pour plein de choses
donc effectivement des travaux très
importants pour une conne et pour comme
ça forge et un effondrement du talus il
y a deux ans a ajouté un affaissement en
rive de chaussée dans la côte des dix
sept tournant ont rendu indispensable
les travaux le département a injecté 400
mille euros pour permettre à la commune
de saint fort g tech il ya les cinq
mille véhicules par jour qui empruntent
cet axe
c'est un chantier qu une commune seule
la petite commune de saint forget et
c'est un peu plus de 500 habitants
n'auraient jamais pu financer n'aurait
jamais eu des génériques
phys hante pour réaliser ce chantier
dont qu'ils avaient besoin du
département deux entreprises du groupe
vinci ont collaboré pour assurer une
consolidation de la chaussée à l'aide de
pioches aurait eu trois phases une
première phase pour faire des petits
travaux préparatoires avant
l'intervention d'entreprises bottes qui
a réalisé les pieux et a pas une fois
qu'ils ont réalisé les pubs on est
revenu pour faire tout le terrassement
de la chaussée une route où tu n'avais
désormais prête à accueillir les
automobilistes qui pour mme au passage
observer une décoration surprise dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche nous sommes
repassés à l'heure d'hiver et ce
pourrait bien être la dernière fois en
février dernier à une grande majorité le
parlement européen a demandé à la
commission européenne de lancer une
évaluation complète avec l'objectif d'en
finir avec le système actuel 3 millions
de citoyens européens se sont d'ailleurs
déclarés en faveur de la fin du
changement d'heure dont lors d'une
consultation citoyenne qui a été lancée
donc cet été bonsoir laetitia moreau
gabart a fait partie de ces citoyens
vous êtes la présidente de l'association
contre l'heure d'été double ached qui
est basée à marly-le-roi première
question pourquoi selon vous faut-il
mettre fin à l'heure d'été quel voilà
pourquoi pourquoi est elle néfaste
settle cette heure d'été alors quand on
parle à l'heure d'été on parle de
changement d'heure mais il ya aussi
l'aspect l'avancement de leurs par
rapport au soleil et en france en
espagne en belgique sont nés deux heures
en avance sur leur de notre fuseau et
ceci est donc le changement c'est tout
le monde voit que ça peut être
problématique ça s'appelle une chrono
rupture ça change nos habitudes mais le
décalage aussi et d'un problème
deux heures c'est très dur pour notre
organisme et d'autres aspects donc voilà
donc par rapport à
à ce décalage notre association elle est
contre l'heure d'été double on a compris
c'est par rapport au méridien de
greenwich le méridien zéro il ya un
décalage de deux heures ses 100 ans en
été par rapport à ce méridien nous
sommes deux heures en avance sur leur de
solaire à peu près 1 mais leur dusuzeau
en fait voilà ça remonte vraiment pour
dire tout depuis 1940
nous avons une heure d'été en fait
puisque depuis 1940 invasion hitler il
nous a mis à l'heure de berlin et depuis
on l'a jamais perdu cet ordre mondial on
a conservé cet heureux ça le monde cette
heure de berlin est là depuis 1940 on
est une heure d'été c'est un plan en
permanence au moins et on appellera
d'isère parce qu'en 76 nous en a rajouté
une autre ça a été l'heure d'été
maintenant dix double donc voila nous
ont fait c'est une butte mais c'est
aussi une résistance
ça fait six ans 18 ans qu'on a une heure
d'été simple et 42 en une heure d'été
double et ce vote du parlement qui s'est
dit favorable largement à la fin de ce
système du changement d'heure est ce que
ça change concrètement la donne à votre
combat a tout à fait les choses bougent
et la forteresse heure d'été se fissure
et on sent enfin tous ne s'en rend pas
tout tout à fait compte complètement il
ya des sondages qui disent à compresser
à l'heure d'été mais en fait le
parlement
la voix donc d'arrêter le changement
d'heure mais aussi la commission elle a
été sommée de faire quelque chose
elle a fait un sondage mais aussi elle
va devoir intégrer d'autres éléments
comme la recommandation 14,32 du conseil
de l'europe qui a demandé en 2001
d'arrêter l'heure d'été voilà donc il va
falloir arrêter l'heure d'été ça fait 42
ans qu'on nous dit que c'est super on
pas du tout et si une raison et sait on
le combat le combat
c'est pas qu'on n'aime pas c'est pas
c'est rationnel pour où il ya la science
il ya les économies il ya la loi c'est
mauvais pour le climat c'est mauvais
pour les économies d'énergie il y en a
pas en fait et des gaspillages on nous a
trop disons il ya eu pas mal de
mensonges depuis 1976 et la pollution
augmente a déclaré t on sait que la
santé physique et intellectuelle aussi
est affecté notre bien-être et donc
arrêter là d'été arrêter le changement
mais aussi choisir la bonne heure
ça va être prendre resté une heure de
décalage par cette décision devra être
prise en tout cas par les différents
pays l'union européenne qui choisiront
finalement entre 7 heures d'été ou
rester à l'heure d'hiver
une dernière question de ce que on
arrive déjà la fin de cet entretien on
l'a compris le combat n'est pas encore
terminé et ce combat elle avait
d'ailleurs et antheaume entamée par
votre mère eléonore gabarain gabarain
pardon qui nous a quitté cet été c'était
important pour vous de continuer son
combat ont la vertu à de nombreuses
reprises sur tv 78 oui oui continuer son
combat celui des adhérents avant elle
avait le professeur sander un pédiatre
qui l'avait commencée l'association ce
sont des résistants est on est on est
pas loin de la victoire
faut juste qu'on choisisse la bonne
heure mais
la loi la science la raison est avec
nous et nous avons peut-être même
l'année prochaine donc en mars
il est possible qu'on ne passe pas à
l'heure d'été 1 comme le portugal en 96
on va pas on peut ne pas changer le
gouvernement français peut le faire et
la décision sera prise dans les
prochains mois pour toute l'actualité
sur votre association n'arrive déjà cet
entretien il ya site internet qui
s'affiche livre de ma mère de 2015 il a
plein d'informations super intéressante
pour tout comprendre de tous les aspects
de l'art d'été de l'histoire commence
assez fait l'erreur de l'heure d'été
merci laëticia moureaux gabarain d'avoir
été avec nous et je rappelle que vous
êtes la présidente de l'association
contre l'heure d'été double merci
d'avoir été avec nous tout de suite
direction la vallée de chevreuse
[Musique]
pour notre focus hebdomadaire nous nous
rendrons à l'espace rambouillet le parc
animalier abrite un centre de soins des
rapaces exclusivement dédié à leur
sauvetage et ils recueillent les oiseaux
de proie blessés et leur vient en aide
un reportage de jules colis c'est au
coeur de l'espace rambouillet que se
trouve le centre de sont des rapaces où
chaque année près de 200 oiseaux de
proies sont recueillis et soignés
des interventions qui peuvent débuter
par l'action de chacun d'entre nous donc
nous recueillons les animaux qu'il en
soit on était découvert en difficulté
très fréquemment au bord de la route
parce qu'ils ont été percutés par les
véhicules également des jeunes oiseaux
dont les nids ont été détruits lors de
travaux même d'événements d'événements
climatiques des tempêtes et les orages
et c est le but de les retaper jusqu'à
ce que nous puissions les les remettre
dans la nature de la chouette au
blizzard en passant par le faucon
crécerelle mais également leur art et
globaux t le centre se doit d'accueillir
correctement ces rapaces et c'est avec
la collaboration du pnr de la vallée de
chevreuse que sont actuellement effectué
des opérations de rénovation
alors ne volèrent d'installation en
général non plus de vingt ans maintenant
et c'est vrai que la plupart des filets
on était déjà réparée
un mouton reprise on a comme sous la
pression de tous les petits prédateurs
naturels qui habitent ici qui étaient là
avant nous mais je leur souhaite
vraiment d'être là après nous donc il
est hors de question de leur faire du
mal mais nous devons avoir des volières
et anchois la fous pour protéger nos
patients avec l'encadrement scientifique
de l'ue fcs union française des centres
de sauvegarde de la faune sauvage
le centre se doit de préparer les
oiseaux pour le retour à la nature aussi
bien psychologiquement que physiquement
pour l'aptitude au vol il faut du muscle
donc on a des voleurs de 20 à 25 mètres
de long on essaie de les faire voler le
plus possible dans pour qu'ils aient la
pêche peut en faire un herbivore il a
juste à se pencher y trouve allongée de
son problème c'est plutôt de survivre
face à un prédateur un prédateur lui
c'est tout le contraire il passe sa vie
à avoir faim et à chercher à s'alimenter
à survivre ça c'est important de nous
donne relâché que les amis des animaux
qui ont ce tempérament là un tempérament
naturel et sauvage normal en fait traîne
au sauvageon au centre de soins c'est
vrai que l'on voit bien que
ils sont attirés par le grand large
globalement leur donne surtout du temps
parce que manifestement ils ont manqué
quoi la plupart des blessures qu'on
soigne son des blessures relativement
légères mais qui les aurait empêché de
trouver à manger serait mort de faim on
le remet en forme on leur remet du
muscle ils sont top
et oui on ouvre la porte voilà la cage
aux oiseaux et c'est sympa c'est là
qu'on se fait plaisir mais si on peut
être utile à la nature tant mieux être
utile à la nature en sauvegardant la
faune sauvage une mission collective
effectuée par les bénévoles du centre
[Musique]
il est re de retour pardon dans ce
journal pour sa chronique sports du
lundi miquel et demi d'euros bonsoir je
tenais à vous remercier vous m'avez
remplacé la semaine dernière a
brillamment je tenais à vous remercier
mais j'ai tenté de le faire de la
meilleure des manières alors pendant les
vacances scolaires il ya quand même du
sport michael dont dans les yvelines on
va commencer cette chronique avec du
rugby du rugby floride j lb
effectivement jouait ce week-end en
championnat de fédérale 2 il aura fallu
attendre la 7e journée pour voir le
rugby club de plaisir remporté sa
première victoire de la saison et
plaisir oise se sont imposés 28 à 8 face
au paris université club
on écoute la réaction du capitaine
françois à le vilain au micro de manon
varaldo on sait qu'il nous faut
absolument une victoire il nous la
fallait absolument et je crois que tout
le monde avait à coeur de bien faire les
choses et défensivement on a suivi a
graissé
et voilà quand on avait tous envie de
bien faire les choses et
voilà ça c'est vu ça s'est senti sur le
terrain en tout cas avec cette victoire
à plaisir quitte la place de lanterne
rouge et remonte à l'avant dernière
place du championnat à seulement un
petit point à du maintien on est dans
une dans une poule qui est très
compliqué nous on est encore tout jeune
à ce niveau-là et du cou et du coup ça
demande beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
coups sacrifice d'abnégation et voilà et
tout le boulot qu'on met en place depuis
la saison depuis le début de saison
il commence à payer et je crois que
c'est ça qui fait vraiment plaisir on
progresse dans le jeu et dans
l'intensité la semaine dernière à drancy
on doit gagner là bas et aujourd'hui on
a réussi à garder le même niveau de jeu
la même intensité
prochain match pour plaisir le 11
novembre sur le terrain de chartres le
cinquième ducasse on espère que ce match
se passera aussi bien que le précédent
pour les plaisirs ou en continu par du
football fa les jeux présents je
prononce bien michael la coupe de france
ce week end le 6e tour de la coupe de
france les yvelines auront deux
représentants au prochain tour de la
compétition
versailles club de nationale 3 s'est
imposé sur la plus petite des marges
contre nanterre qui évolue en r 2 score
final 1-0 autres qualifiés cariat
grésillons les événements remporté le
derby contre verneuil-sur-seine à
domicile s'impose 1 à 0 et devienne le
plus le petit poucet national de cette
coupe de france
c'est terminé en revanche pour poissy
qui s'incline aux tirs au but contre
drancy le prochain tour est programmé
dans trois semaines des yvelinois
connaîtront leur adversaire mercredi
prochain vous souhaite bonne chance à
nosy be noël merci michael ces résultats
bien d'autres encore à suivre dans votre
émission il a paru le 7 8 sport s'est
assuré après lé journal mais avant de
refermer à cette édition c'est un grand
monsieur de la télé qui nous a quittés
philippe gildas est décédé ce week-end à
l'âge de 82 ans et nous avions eu le
plaisir de l'accueillir atv 78 le 30
septembre 2017 pour l'une de ses
dernières apparitions télévisées le
journaliste et animateur était venu
rendre visite à l'époque à patrice
carnot et ses chroniqueurs et dont
l'émission paf
elle est à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
c'est la fin du set 8 journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]
oh